columnas de humo y fuego tras un ataque
con drones rusos sobre kiev los
servicios de emergencia atendían los
daños el alcalde vitaliccheco desde el
sitio del ataque aprovechó para acusar a
Rusia y asesinar a civiles
no es el primer edificio de apartamentos
en nuestra ciudad natal donde la gente
fue asesinada tenemos más de 200
edificios de apartamentos destruidos por
los ataques rusos donde mataron a mucha
gente civiles gente No culpable y eso es
porque Estos son ataques terroristas
Rusia es un país terrorista
desde tierra las fuerzas ucranianas
intentaban repeler el ataque Hasta la
policía disparaba al cielo para poder
interceptar a los drones no tripulados
la fuerza aérea reportó que lograron
detener un alto porcentaje
el total hemos destruido 37 drones
kamikaze todos ellos volaron desde el
sur nuestro recuento preliminar muestra
que al menos entre el 85 y el 96% Fueron
destruidos por nuestra defensa aérea
desde Luxemburgo el ministro de
exteriores danés condenó la ofensiva
rusa
esta mañana hemos vuelto a ver aquí
abajo el ataque ruso
por lo que es muy importante que
respondamos con decisión por parte de la
Unión Europea y por nuestra parte para
mí es muy importante que establezcamos
una misión de entrenamiento militar de
la Unión Europea para Ucrania y también
que liberemos más dinero para
suministrar Ucrania las armas
los ataques rusos sobre la capital los
segundos en una semana se producen por
una posible represalia por parte de
Moscú tras acusar a Ucrania del
bombardeo del puente de crimea y de un
depósito de crudo en la ciudad
fronteriza rusa de Ucrania en su
contraofensiva ha hecho perder terreno
en varias regiones ocupadas por el
kremlin